Play and there'll be like white guy
for sure. Let's play. No gambling.
Just like having a fun
time. Really? Oh yeah. Yeah.
I saw one in Chiang Mai in that
downtown marketplace area. Yeah,
I saw one. How Fun was that? Fucking
Thai kickboxing. Pretty Fun tie fight.
It's so cool. And they played
the the instrument, right, dude?
How fucking fun is that?
Yeah, it's pretty wild.
I've been to those out
here where they play it,
but Americans get real bored with
the y crew. The dance. They do.
Yeah. They do a dance for their, for
their own Dojo. Yeah. Well they do.
Everybody does it and there's
a real logic behind it.
The logic is that you warm up and
that you really, you relax yourself,
you're kind of performing in front of
all these dance moves and also people are
staring at you, so it kind of wears off
your nerves. There's a reality to that.
It's, it's actually really wise and you
lose, you limber up your body to like,
a lot of the stuff they're doing is
they're getting down on one knee like a
lunge and they're bouncing a little bit
and so the limb bring up their body and
then on top of that they're actually
doing this dance in front of all these
people and it calms the nerves a
little bit. Wow. Yeah. John Fix.
We're always talking about that. About
like the idea of people watching you.
It's actually a big thing and the UFC is
like a bigger people watching you then.
Oh yeah. Anywhere else. It's a tougher
people watching you is fucking hot,
you know? I mean people watching him
shoot a free throw, you know? Good Dude.
Good Dude. Bunch people watch it. Oh
fuck. Here we go. Here we go. That's real.
Even if it's just like five of
your friends. Yeah. Yeah. Pressure.
The pressure's in fucking real man.
I mean,
that's what everybody's most terrified
about what we do. Public speaking,
I had somebody that we were given
a talk on Shakespeare or some,
it was a group project.
We each had to write one paragraph.
We wrote three paragraphs.
Each one of us read one,
so I think I read mine just
reading it off a paper.
It was paying attention in this next day
was like, and then later Shakespeare,
I was just looking at her
like what the fuck? And the
teacher was like, okay, okay,
okay. It's all right, let's go. Let's
[inaudible] was rude and I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Crazy. It's weird. It was a stand up.
But like yeah,
the sense I used to panic when I would
talk to bank tellers. What? Yeah.
I used to go to a bank teller.
It gets super nervous right before I'd
have to talk to a bank teller. Why?
I don't know. It's no reason
for it. When I was a kid I've,
I really felt like a loser.
I really did.
I had like serious low self esteem issues
up until like high school you up until
martial arts.
And then once I started doing martial
arts and getting really good at it and
then teaching, it kind of calmed
me down. Experience. Yeah.
And then it kind of like,
was it, believe it or not,
almost like a natural path to stand
up. But I remember before that, uh,
being very awkward, talking
to people, like very nervous,
talking to people I didn't
know and I just didn't,
it didn't feel like I still get that
where I'm like, I don't know how to talk.
I just trying to draw. I don't know
how to talk to. Yeah, I know, right.
Especially if it's an odd
thing. And so, you know,
it's was worse when they know you too,
and answer your questions. So broad.
What's Joey Diaz like? Oh boy. What's
he like? Yeah, that's, that's hard.
Hey Man. Of got to ask you a
question, which I do for a living.
Trying to get my shit together.
Okay. Fired. Fired truck operator.
You should make ladders. Yeah. Like,
I don't know anything about you.